Barbara Walters after 50-plus years
doing network television she has
announced her retirement and earlier
this week on the view she actually gave
us a date let's take a look you may
remember that last spring I said that I
would leave daily television in a year
so here we are it's almost one year
later and I have decided that Friday May
16th will be my final appearance on the
view as a co-host will be a two-hour ABC
News primetime special looking back at
my career for over 50 continuous years
on a year man I've been doing a youtube
show for a year and I think that's a
long time 50 consecutive years on air so
I want to talk about Barbara first and
then we'll talk about the view why is it
that Barbara Walters doesn't get into
that gay icon status that these older
women seem to get into of course for me
the Golden Girls but all there's just
plenty of older women you know Judy
Garland whoever that the gay community
loves for some reason Barbara Walters
even though she's a proponent of gay
rights and it's on TV every day and
talking about liberal causes things like
that she never made it there for some
reason I just I find it hard to trust
anyone with eyes that are just that big
a problem with a woman with work come on
no yeah I don't you know I I think that
she comes across as like a little
pretentious at the same time I
appreciate the barriers that she has
broken down and that she was like really
at the forefront of what she was doing
but I just don't feel like the same warm
fuzzy I don't know she kind of strikes
me as a [ __ ] just kind of Wow all right
so that point is is it partly because
she's a news woman so she's more serious
than gays like over-the-top right days
like camp she doesn't have a drag
doppelganger I think is the thing it's
hard to you're right it's hard to
impersonate her and you know all of our
icons are performers mostly yeah they're
easier to emulate and Betty White is a
comedian even though she's not a singer
yeah but shouldn't we love someone like
Barbara Walters who did break down all
those barriers
is actually doing something I mean she
did she did for women what we want
someone to do for gay people right I
think we do love her I love her I highly
respect her I think she's fierce as how
I wished she liked rains in the view and
like her cuts Oh co-hosts down as they
step out a lot brings a man and I think
people really respect her I certainly
really adore her and I think she's find
her to be inspirational and very
ambitious but I think you've I never
thought about this but yeah she's
difficult to like iconic eyes whatever
whatever that word is right so let's
talk about the view a little bit because
I think there's something really
fascinating with the view and gay people
i there was a couple years where I watch
the view every day when Rosie was on and
joy was on they were so amazing together
there Rosie obviously is gay joy is as
close to gay as possible I guess without
being gay what is it about the view and
what is it about a group of women that
are outspoken that gays love because if
there was a show of five gay guys
sitting around a table or four gay guys
gays would not be into it we would never
mind so so what is that what is that
well I I like to watch it because I like
to see how like disinterested joy is and
she's just like trying to get through
the show that she's just like is this
really another week of the view it's
probably why she left with you after
what tour she was on for twelve years or
something like yeah yeah it's I think
you can't paint all gay people with a
broad brush that like all gay people
like the view but it's the same reason
that people like the view it's it's a
distraction from everyday life like
there's a lot of drama there's a lot of
cattiness that goes on and and you know
people people like that it's what is it
reading yeah it's like kind of like
meaningless uh okay yeah okay right what
is it though about what is it though
about gay guys that are you guys with me
that if it had been a table of four gay
guys that it never would have done
nearly as well as having women maybe
middle-aged women would have liked it
I was middle-aged women love gay guys
but that gay guys wouldn't have been as
into it if it had been gay guys at the
table I agree I think it's I think
there's not as wide of appeal if it's
all just gay men but that's a cultural
thing for another yeah that's an
other side conversation but I'm talking
about for gay men watching it why is it
that gay men would be more inclined to
watch a group of women at a table than
game at a table I think it's the same
reason why gay men who loved sex in the
city because that show those were gay
men masquerading as women I think the
the cast of the view those are gay men
masquerading as women I think those
conversations remind us of private
conversations that we have I think we
love the fashion we love the hair we
there's there's a certain element of
glam and and it's elevated it's it's
heightened it's our lives heightened for
you know and now you're right we can't
paint it with the big brush but their
appeal is the same reason that the
reality shows have appeal
yeah and fashion shows have appeal so so
there you go yeah
all right final thought on this I was
thinking you know Barbara said the thing
about the the 50 years and all that do
you think that's just like a thing
that's long gone people that are gonna
have these sort of iconoclastic I think
before careers where they last 50 years
in the business is she really one of the
sort of I don't want to call her a
dinosaur but you know II mean is she is
that it really that we won't have people
that last this long in this kind of
business well I mean it I don't think so
I think there's going to be other people
that they're doing that but the
important thing with Barbara Walters is
that Lea she broke down so many barriers
that stood in her way that like like in
that sense she's legendary and what she
did and there will be other people at
the front of their game doing things
that have never been done but those were
some like really big walls to break down
yeah so I guess there aren't that many
walls to break down hopefully right I
think different walls are just to pop up
not right for her right now so we're not
for people of her you know not for white
women in broadcasting right there'll be
other walls to break down